hey real quick i want to say thank you
to storyblocks who's the sponsor of
today's video
i've used storybox for like the better
part of a decade because
it is a giant repository of visual and
audio assets that i can use for my
videos you may not know this but
in this video that you're watching i've
used a bunch of story blocks footage
because i just go there all of the time
to download an unlimited amount
of high-res royalty-free stock footage
and i don't pay for each individual clip
i just pay one subscription
and i get unlimited downloads
storyblocks has not only stock footage
but also after effects templates and
sound effects it is a
giant repository of amazing visual and
audio assets
and again i've been using them long
before they ever came to sponsor a video
for me because i
love storyblocks so thank you
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
go to storyblocks.com johnny harris to
get started
today with storyblocks so you can make
more videos okay
let's get back to the story there's this
one moment captured on film that i can't
seem to get out of my mind
there's a boat sailing the waters to the
remote island
of iceland in 1938 there are smiling
faces and tourists doing what they've
always done and will continue to do
exploring the vastness of this country
and then there's shots of
children smiling playing living it's
honestly
beautiful footage but when you pause
this clip and think about
who is the person holding this camera
the person zoomed in to all of these
kids smiling faces these
people alive and well the person holding
this camera
is hitler's girlfriend her name was eva
braun
she was the longtime confidant
girlfriend and
eventual wife of adolf hitler the only
person who could call him by his name
and the one who bit into a cyanide pill
alongside him as they both ended their
lives together
in a small study in berlin as germany
was losing the war
oh and this footage was taken just a few
months before hitler invaded poland
to start the bloodiest war of all time
so who was she
and why was she on a tour in iceland
and i guess most importantly what role
did iceland play
in hitler's grand plans to take over the
[Music]
world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ava braun met hitler while working in
munich as a model
and assistant to hitler's photographer
they got together
when she was 19 and he was 42 and she
remained the closest person to hitler
leading up to and during the war ava was
a photographer
and is responsible for many of the
images and film we have of hitler today
hitler wanted to keep their relationship
a secret because he thought
being a bachelor would like give him a
wider appeal
among germany's women okay big pr guy
hitler was
he would always say he was married to
germany
okay so it's summer 1939 hitler is
literally two months away from
invading poland and starting world war
ii
and ava is on a nazi boat with this
sweet
swimming pool on it i want a boat with a
swimming pool and they're traveling to
iceland they visit the geyser
and see all the hot water and the steam
and the volcanic rocks and they're in
reykjavik i mean this doesn't look too
much different from
my trip in iceland anyway it turns out
that
the nazi leadership was kind of obsessed
with iceland
and not because of the black sand
beaches and glaciers but
because of the people
[Music]
specifically this guy henrik himmler the
big dog in the nazi regime the literal
architect of the holocaust he was the
one who loved iceland the most
he loved the viking lore and legends but
he also had this
twisted enthusiasm for the fact that the
whole country was
white icelanders in himmler's mind were
the pure superior nordic race that he
thought the nazi message would resonate
with
insane so as the nazis were gaining
power in germany they turned to iceland
they bought an apartment
in the capital reykjavik and they sent
this guy
a nazi loyalist who was tasked with
being a diplomat to iceland his job was
very simple to commune with the racially
pure
icelandic people and fulfill himmler's
dream of converting them to nazism
more on how that went later but real
quick another reason that the nazis were
so into iceland
was because of this these are the convoy
routes between the uk and
the northern hemisphere this is where
goods supplies
ammo troops would be moved between
the two regions see how these routes run
right past iceland 1800 air miles from
halifax
825 miles from scotland and only 900
from nazi held norway the nazis realized
that if they could take over iceland and
have a base here
it would render this route way too
dangerous
so yeah the nazis were kind of into
iceland
not just because of the racial makeup of
the people and the abundant resources
but also because of the prime strategic
location
in the impending war okay so let's fast
forward to a year after
eva braun's trip to iceland it's 1940
the war has started the nazis have
started conquering their neighbors
moving into denmark norway and soon
sweden
meanwhile iceland is remaining a neutral
country a reminder that remaining
neutral during world war ii isn't easy
but anyway iceland is remaining neutral
and the diplomat who the nazis had sent
to iceland is still there
he's still working on recruiting the
icelanders to the nazi
cause and not having tons of success he
recruited like a small group of college
kids
to the cause and overall he's kind of
disappointed in iceland the place is not
what himmler thought it was but he
doesn't tell anyone back home he doesn't
want to disappoint the nazi regime
instead
he confides in his journal complaining
that iceland's theaters
perform plays written by jews and that
they have no
apples in their stores like that's your
complaint it's like oh
they have no apples in the stores like i
hate this country
he also complained that they held their
forks
with their right hands like shovels oh
gosh this was not the aryan utopia
that he was hoping for but still iceland
had strategic value
the nazi army is moving north and you
know who's most freaked out by this
by this movement north this guy winston
churchill
leader of the uk at the time churchill
said
quote whoever possesses iceland holds a
pistol
firmly pointed at england and america
and canada yeah that's that pretty much
sums it up
churchill had been trying to convince
iceland to join their side
but iceland was like no we have a
hundred thousand people we have no army
we're gonna remain neutral and churchill
becomes impatient
so in may of 1940 not even a year after
ava braun's getaway to iceland
churchill sends in his navy they showed
up to iceland on a mission called
operation fork sort of weird name but
whatever so the navy arrives to the port
of reykjavik not to an
army but to a bunch of locals like why
is there a giant navy
arriving to our country remember iceland
doesn't have an army
so they sent the local police to tell
the british navy
that they were in violation of iceland's
sovereignty
the british troops were like yeah i know
anyway could you tell all these people
to move so we can
dock our boats and let our marines off
and the icelandic police were like
yeah okay sure no conflict no
confrontation
the british are politely invading
iceland
the most cordial invasion ever they did
this because they were freaked out that
the nazis would do it first the first
thing they do when they show up
is go to the german diplomats house they
show up and start
knocking on the door and they're like
hey german diplomat we just invaded
iceland so that the nazis can't by the
way you're arrested
and the diplomat from the other side of
the room literally said this is a quote
he said
you can't do that iceland is a neutral
nation
in the war and the british troops said
and again this is a quote
oh yeah neutral like denmark was neutral
like norway was neutral these were
neutral countries too
that didn't stop you guys from invading
so the diplomat is sitting there trying
to get his furnace to work so it can
burn all these documents before the
british
break in and arrest him which they
eventually did when they broke in
they found a shrine to hitler in his
house he had burned a lot of documents
but he didn't burn his diary which is
why we know this guy really actually
didn't like iceland so yeah
now the british have troops in iceland
but as the war rages on
britain realizes that they needed troops
elsewhere they can't afford to have all
these troops just sitting in iceland as
placeholders
so they call upon their friends the
americans they're like america can you
please help us out with troops and
america's like no we already told you
we're not getting involved in the war
because at this time america was not
involved in the war they were
neutral so britain is like okay is there
a loophole here so britain
asks iceland to ask america to come
help them as one neutral nation to
another america is like okay cool i can
do that
another union if not actually of allies
then certainly of two armies with the
same objective
was cemented when american troops joined
ours in iceland
with iceland in his hands hitler could
have controlled our sea lanes but
accepting an invitation from the
icelandic government
we got there first so before the u.s
ever got
officially involved in the war which
happened when japan bombed pearl harbor
before all of that they sent 25 000
troops to iceland
to hold down the fort so that the
british troops could go
fight elsewhere at first the icelanders
didn't take to the strange faces and
uniforms which began to appear on the
street
i freaking love 1940s american military
documentaries
they're just so they're just so bizarre
some are steaming hot and come in very
handy when they want their long-handled
john's fresh and dainty for that
saturday inspection while in iceland the
americans start building
roads and bunkers and ports and bases
the united states army is laying better
road beds
and is widening and strengthening the
bridges to permit the passage of heavier
trucks
and tanks this is stuff that is still
there today
a lot of icelanders see this as a
blessing since it helped upgrade their
infrastructure
helped give them like big beautiful
roads around the country but
rightfully so many feel like they were
used as a pawn by these super powers
that violated their sovereignty in the
name of
geo strategy which is absolutely what
happened
as always with occupation it's
complicated anyway but you know what i'm
super
curious what icelanders actually think
about this history
was the invasion of britain and the
subsequent presence of
the united states a blessing to iceland
or was this a
deep violation of their sovereignty or
both i'm super curious and
will gladly read comments from any
icelander who has thoughts on this
[Music]
so the americans eventually got totally
involved in the war
as we know and they helped turn the nazi
tide and eventually the allies defeated
the nazis
in europe hitler and eva braun knew it
was coming to an end they didn't want to
face the justice that was going to be
dealt them for the atrocities committed
by
hitler's regime so they took their own
lives in berlin in 1945
as it was all coming to an end and as
for iceland the troops eventually left
and
icelanders were sort of done being a
part of this global system that could
just
throw them around like a pond they had
been a part of the kingdom of denmark
in some way but but right after the war
they voted 97
to move away from the danish crown and
become totally
independent an independent republic
which is what they are today
and they remain quite neutral and
independent with no army
no membership in the eu and despite the
great powers who tried to persuade them
and occupy them iceland has retained its
unique
and independent culture a couple years
ago i got to interview the prime
minister of iceland when i was making
an episode of explained for vox i
learned about how iceland leads the
world in
gender equality in happiness in energy
sustainability
it's a special place and not because it
is strategically located
i will certainly be back many times over
the years
thanks for watching